the first person in the United States
diagnosed with ebola has died we just
received that report from Texas Health
uh this was a man who had come to the
United States indirectly from Liberia uh
he was admitted to hospital with uh
symptoms that soon were diagnosed as
Ebola and he has uh he has recently died
as I say we just received that report uh
we also mentioned earlier this morning
that the homeland security department
has ordered agents at airports and other
ports of Entry to the United States to
observe everyone coming into the US for
potential signs of Ebola infection uh
officials uh have been have put this in
place as of today uh we do not have any
immediate details uh as to what specific
measures are going to be taken and when
they will be put in place but um the
announcement was made today again the
first patient diagnosed with ebola on us
soil has died